our own old goodbye
number five okay hey guys I'm a t-shirt
welcome to Abby's kitchen it's finally
here
Health Canada has finally released its
new Canada's Food Guide as of about a
month ago and I have a lot to say about
it today I'm gonna walk you through some
of the differences and changes for
seeing what the new food guide compared
to older versions what I'm liking and
what I'm not liking so let's do this
let's talk about some of the differences
in the layout of the guide number one
goodbye recommended servings so this
recommendation was overdue for an
overhaul for so long I'm really excited
to see that it's now being changed up so
in my experience as a dietitian I found
that a lot of people had a lot of
trouble with the concept of serving
sizes and also meeting some of these
recommendations set out by the food
guide so even for myself for example
with the Greens it was recommended that
I'm supposed to have six to seven grain
servings every day that amounts to about
three and a half cups of grains every
single day and while some people would
have no problem meeting this
recommendation just based on their diet
and will based on that day I found that
once I was getting all the protein
servings in and all the the milk and you
know the meat and all the fruits and
vegetables I was stuffed I was full I
was feeling overwhelmed with the amount
of food that the diffict I was
recommending for me so I can definitely
see why it can be a bit of a struggle
for a lot of people to follow some of
these recommended serving sizes number
two goodbye food groups so our old food
guide features this beautiful colorful
rainbow with our fruits and vegetables
we had our grains that we had our milk
and alternatives that our meat and
alternatives so instead of our rainbow
we are now seeing a plate method with
some very simple messaging we've got
some really nice broad categories
instead of the food groups they are
fruits and vegetables protein rich foods
whole grains and then of course water as
our drink of choice number three goodbye
focus on animal-based products now don't
get me wrong I still totally enjoy meat
in moderation
however the past I took really put
animal products as the center point of a
balanced meal in this new guide there's
definitely still room for meat and milk
and other animal-based foods in our day
however they're really trying to
emphasize the need to get more
plant-based foods into our diet so
here's what I like about the guide
number one it emphasizes that healthy
eating is more than just the food that
we eat so it looks like Health Canada
has taken a tip out of the Brazilian
food guide which is often what we see is
the gold standard and food guide and
it's presented Canadians with some
animal tips to combat some the external
triggers that we have when it comes to
interfering with her ability to eat
healthy so rather than just focusing on
what eat the new food guide is trying to
focus also on how to eat and it's
touching on concepts like mindful eating
cooking at home with friends and family
reading and understanding food labels
and understanding food marketing as well
number two the emphasis on filling half
of your play with veggies as a dietitian
this is definitely a message that I've
been trying to share for a very long
time and now it's so exciting to see our
national guy flecked that message as
well so I think that seeing our
vegetables displayed on a plate like
we've seen now the new food guy
method is so much more effective as a
communication strategy than trying to
encourage people to count out and
calculate all of these arbitrary serving
sizes so I definitely think this is a
big win on Health Canada's part and
number three it encourages water for
hydration in an effort to kind of combat
all the sugar sweetened beverages there
are on the market I'm really happy to
see the Health Canada is emphasizing the
og and hydration water and they're doing
that by putting a glass of water front
and center on the first page of that
guide
Bravo so here's what I don't like about
the guide first of all you definitely
need to be super tech savvy to get it so
most of the information that is found in
the guide is accessible only really
online you have to dig deep to find it
and honestly I spend my whole life
online this is my whole job and even I
found it really hard to navigate the
website and find all the information
that I'm looking for so I can only
imagine how frustrating it would be for
some of our older Canadians who are
maybe a little less tech savvy to find
what they're looking for or maybe it's a
newcomer to Canada and just getting
started we're - it might actually be too
broad so one of the big criticisms of
the old guide was that it contained a
lot of very specific information all
those numbers and that made it really
hard for the layperson to make any sense
of it at all so the new guy does
certainly a lot more broad in its
recommendations however this might make
it a lot harder for us to inform public
policy like healthy school programs or
hospital meals number three there is no
discussion of body positivity and diet
culture yes I love that the new guide
has finally touch on mindful eating but
this is a very complex topic and I
really don't think that we can dive deep
into it without first addressing body
positivity and diet culture I mean it is
absolutely impossible to encourage or
teach anybody to try to eat mindfully
when they're fully engrossed in diet
culture number four it lacks cultural
relevance okay so where is my bok choy
at Health Canada you need to take a look
at our demographic we are made up of so
many amazing rich cultures and we need a
food guide that actually reflects that
not to mention the food guide is one of
the first documents that are handed over
to newcomers to Canada when they come
here and a guide like this likely will
make very little sense to them in the
future I hope the Health Canada will
ditch its Eurocentric lens and include a
diverse array of foods to help speak to
a wide variety of cultures number five
it lasts accessibility so past and
current food guides have really failed
to point out one of Canada's big
epidemics and that is food insecurity
this boot guide encourages Canadians to
eat seasonally to cook more at home with
family and friends and to feel half
their plate with fruits and vegetables
and that's great but what about the four
million Canadians who are shopping at
food banks and not at farmers markets
seriously one in eight Canadian
households are struggling to get any
food on their plate
never mind fill half of it with
beautiful colorful vegetables and this
food guide is really not taking that
into consideration and finally let's
talk nutrition there seems to be a lack
of direction on the types of foods in
these categories so since we no longer
have food groups a little more direction
and distinction when it comes to these
broad categories might be helpful for
most Canadians so for example not all
fruits and vegetables are nutritionally
created equal a potato for example I
would say a potato would better fit in
that greens category because it starts
here then let's say the spinach does on
your plate likewise some fruit are
obviously a lot higher in sugar than a
lot of the vegetables that are on that
side of the plate I mean I wouldn't
recommend that anybody just fill their
fleet half only with fruit but with this
food guide that seems totally fair game
and finally I would love to see a little
category for fats
I mean weirdest avocado bit currently
it's considered a fruit and vegetable
but again I probably wouldn't recommend
someone fill a half of their plate with
avocado three times a day I would love
to see that carved out in a future guide
to make it a little bit easier for
Canadians
so guys I hope you found this critique
of Canada's Food Guide helpful I would
love to hear from you in the comments
below what do you want to see in a
future reboot of the Canada's Food Guide
what would you like to see in your food
guide if you're from another country
please leave me a comment below don't
forget to give me the thumbs up
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time on Abbey's kitchen bye
[Music]